hey what's up guys my name is Archana
welcome back to my OpenGL series so
today we're gonna be talking about
uniforms and shaders and specifically I
wanted to talk about how we can case
uniforms and in general just how we can
deal with uniforms in a bit of a smarter
way because we all know how to kind of
set uniforms I've got a video on
uniforms in OpenGL and shaders and all
that stuff check that out if you haven't
already but specifically instead of just
retrieving uniforms from OpenGL from
algae of you every single time we need
to set a uniform there are many
different things that we can actually do
to kind of retain that location and take
advantage of the fact that once uniforms
have kind of been retrieved
you know once we've compiled our shader
we've got that actual kind of shader
object on our GPU and of course the
shadow in the GPU is aware of all of the
uniforms that are kind of contained
within and all of the valid uniforms
once we've kind of got all that data
there's no reason for us to continually
query the GPU being like hey please tell
me what like wear my uniform is because
we should already know that stuff and as
you know as you should know pretty much
any OpenGL call that you actually run is
gonna be slower than a lot of the C++
style stuff that you can actually do
because a lot of it actually hits the
GPU and thus kind of requires a little
bit more processing power and takes more
time then if we did something a lot more
simple so today specifically we're gonna
talk about caching that uniform so that
we can just kind of retrieve the
location at any time we want basically
building a little system a very very
simple system that just holds on to a
uniform location for a given name that
we have inside our kind of simple aside
shader object but in general I may talk
about this a little bit more in the
future because what you typically
happens is once you actually compile
your shader pretty much every kind of
game engine or every kind of rendering
engine is actually going to physically
read that shader source code and then
determine what to kind of do with that
right so in other words if we just kind
of load a shader and we compile it and
we use opengl still all that stuff
another very useful thing for us to do
is actually kind of read this the shader
source code
inside C++ and then extract data from it
so from that you can actually find out
all the attributes all of the uniforms
all of the functions everything that is
in the shader we can write a program
essentially that just kind of reads that
text that shader source code and then
from there it can intelligently almost
convert it into actual data that we can
leverage and use at runtime and so in us
in a setup like that where you've got a
proper system and a proper engine like
that you would typically just read your
shader source code and then find all of
the uniforms in the actual shader text
and then retrieve all the locations or
validate or all the uniforms basically
when you're compiling your shader
so in that case anytime you get you know
when when your renderer is actually
setting uniforms in your shader all of
that stuff has already been done
you already have all the locations you
can easily check to see if a uniform
even exists or not without touching
OpenGL why because you've read the
shader source code so that is something
that would happen in a more complete
system what I'm showing you guys today
is a quick and dirty little kind of hack
if you will just to speed up your
program a little bit if you're just
building something quick in OpenGL
you don't want to have this massive like
rendering engine or anything like that
set up and you just want to come speed
up your code quickly without much effort
really by just kind of you knows almost
like one simple trick to faster uniform
setting it's kind of all this is right
in fact if I name the video that I'll
probably just get in trouble with all of
you guys I might not name it one simple
trick to speed up your uniform maybe I
will we'll see but the point is it's
super simple and it's a way that we can
just easily speed up our uniform setting
but just not retrieving the location
every time from OpenGL but by caching it
let's take a look so I have this very
very simple shader class that we have
here kind of leftover from the OpenGL
series and what it has really is and
what it represents is just basically a
shader which contains you know a
rendering ID so it's like a kind of like
a compiled shader object this is like
the CPU representation of an actual
compiled and create a chata object on
our GPU
a bunch of functions for like binding
and unbinding it and also setting all of
these uniforms so this is kind of the
meat of everything and if we take a look
at what that code actually does it
really release
imple all it really does is for every
uniform that we set here such as let's
say a three component vector here avec
three it gets the location from the from
opengl right using our render ID and the
name of the uniform and then it sets
that uniform right now i mean we've got
this jail call macro by the way which is
quite old and not something you would
typically use nowadays but and you know
you can see this location stuff isn't
wrapped in that macro but that's besides
the point if we were to just make us
even more readable it's kind of map one
of that then this is kind of like what
we end up with really really simple
right
we basically retrieve the location if we
want to set the uniform we get the
location here which is gonna be an
integer and then we use that here and
you could even use some kind of
validation to make sure that that
actually exists because we know that if
it is negative one right then it's
invalid so what we might do is something
like this this is a very very common
code that you see in opengl quite often
right where someone basically recruits
the location checks to see if the
location is like negative one or not and
then incest the uniform and that's it
that's done that's gonna work
beautifully but the problem is it's a
little bit inefficient because again as
I mentioned this is gonna be a piece of
hot code that if you hit it often you're
gonna run into problems and we could
even like test that out by just using
the profiler here I think if we go like
you know debug profiler performace
Explorer oh you know we're sure that we
kind of show that and start like a new
performance session and take a look if
we had a program that was you know
setting uniforms every frame you'd see
that this would come up as kind of a hot
piece of code right because this is
something that's gonna get hit often
every time right and since it is a jail
call it takes a bit of time to do so
what we can do instead is grab this
location as you can see we're doing
right and then store it in just a
hashmap so if we hop over to our header
file what we can do is just include an
unordered map and then over here we'll
just type in an STD unordered map now a
key here is going to be our actual name
so a string which represents the name of
our uniform that we want to convert Rev
and then a GL and is gonna be the value
right because
it's actually the open gel I identify
that we use for that particular uniform
location we can call this a uniform
location cache right and then what this
is going to essentially do and we're
actually going to use this is every time
that we want to retrieve a location
we'll check to see if it is this in the
map and if it does then no need for us
to actually retrieve it from OpenGL to
do that we're going to make a little
convenience function for ourselves
called gel int and I'll come put this at
the bottom here GL into guest uniform
location this is again going to take in
a Const string reference which is going
to be our actual name and is going to
return a GL int right but what this
function is going to do is it's going to
be a little bit different than what we
currently have if I just kind of created
here what it's going to do is only get
the location again if it's already check
the cache the first step is to check the
cache and see if we've actually got that
value in there so if this you know if
this uniform location cache actually
contains so if we use find here with the
name as the key if this actually already
exists if the cache contains a uniform
with this name so basically we can do
that by just saying if it doesn't equal
uniform location cache and then we just
return that simple as that so we'll just
do a uniform location cache name like
this okay what this does is just returns
the caged value that already exists
inside our data structure and that means
that what our work is done now if it's
not in the cache then what we need to do
is retrieve it just by using this code
here right then store it in the cache
which we can do by just clapping in
univille like education name equals
location right so we're now storing it
in the case and then obviously we still
need to return it because this function
that retrieves the uniform location
all right simple as that one other thing
I would do potentially is Mark this code
this function as Const the reason being
that you know this is just kind of it's
what it is is it's supposed to be
something that just retrieves the
uniform location it's not really
modifying our shader or doing anything
at all of that nature
now since like if we do marketers
constant you'll notice we will actually
get
an error the reason we'll get an error
is because we're actually modifying
uniform location cache we're setting it
right over here and as you can see that
results in an error and this error right
here by the way is totally it just
hasn't compiled it so that's totally
fine but this is actually a real error
if I had control of seven you'll see
that that's not gonna work so what we
need to do is basically mark our uniform
location cash as a mutable variable what
that means is that it can be modified by
a Const function now this might be a
little bit counterintuitive why are you
creating a mutable variable like Y month
is function is cost but again I'm
explaining that the reason this
functions Marcus Const is because the
actual operation is just reading the
location of our uniform write the
underlying implementation caches the
value but that's not important to the
caller basically it's it's not really
modifying it's not really modifying our
shader at all what it is doing is just
keeping information inside a cage which
is totally fine okay so now that we've
got this instead of doing all of this
stuff every time and getting our
location manually what we can just do
now is call this get uniform location
with the name and that's it that is what
allocation becomes so now what happens
and we'll demonstrate this in a minute I
just quickly replace all of these now
what happens if I put a breakpoint here
and run this program okay so now that
I'm running my program you can see that
we're trying to set this Model View
projection matrix uniform to a certain
value what happens is it's going to of
course run this gate uniform location
function which the first time this runs
the cache is of course somewhat empty I
mean in this case it's actually got you
color a new texture already in there but
it doesn't as you can see doesn't have
the MVP location stored at all so
obviously it's not gonna find it and
then it's going to actually retrieve
that location from OpenGL store it
inside the cache and then return that
location and then if I hit f5 and we
come back to the next time we ask for
this MV P matrix location right the
uniform location cage obviously contains
it which means that now it just simply
returns this uniform location as you can
see and that is a lot faster than
actually querying OpenGL and being like
hey what's this uniform location ok so
that's pretty much all there is to it
helped you out drop a like below nothing
you could do is test this out of course
in your codebase see how much faster it
is just run a quick like write a quick
timer that compares the performance
before and after and you can share your
results in the comments section below I
will see you next time goodbye
[Music]